This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）带来的《吸取教训》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须这么做，请收听
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.|||在AHA广播应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《吸取教训》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改过这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。成群结队的网络侦探花费了大量时间才揭露出一个令人不安的规律。还有两名男子也经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||我的脑子彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《困于爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《困于爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理坚韧、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你终将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t”。当一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners,
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners,|||相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝，在iHeartRadio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，
wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we uncover the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to talk about healing, past trauma, in a new relationship. Romantic relationships in our 20s are so difficult because there is no guidebook to have, how we should be going about it.
wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we uncover the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to talk about healing, past trauma, in a new relationship. Romantic relationships in our 20s are so difficult because there is no guidebook to have, how we should be going about it.|||无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，我们将一起揭开二十岁心理学的神秘面纱。今天，我们要讨论的是在新恋情中治愈过去的创伤。我们二十岁的浪漫关系是如此艰难，因为根本没有一本指南来告诉我们该如何处理。
There are so many questions that go along with that, like, should I delete the dating apps and try and meet someone organically? How long does it take to get over someone? When do I know it's time to break up with my significant other? But one of the biggest questions or conundrums I get all the time, which I will admit I've personally faced is, do you have to be healed before entering into a new relationship? That is a massive question.
There are so many questions that go along with that, like, should I delete the dating apps and try and meet someone organically? How long does it take to get over someone? When do I know it's time to break up with my significant other? But one of the biggest questions or conundrums I get all the time, which I will admit I've personally faced is, do you have to be healed before entering into a new relationship? That is a massive question.|||随之而来的是无数的问题，比如：我应该删除约会软件，尝试通过自然的方式结识某人吗？需要多长时间才能忘记一个人？我怎么知道什么时候该和另一半分手？但我经常遇到、也是我必须承认自己也曾亲身经历过的最大问题或困惑之一是：在进入一段新感情之前，你必须完全治愈自己吗？这是一个巨大的问题。
We undoubtedly carry baggage, trauma, memories, past experiences from the people we have dated and loved and been connected to. And some of that baggage is not great, is not pleasant. And it's perhaps something that we're not ready to unpack yet. But does that mean that if you have not done all the necessary healing, you should hold off on love? Or can you equally heal whilst being with someone new, someone who treats you well and helps you into that kind of self-acceptance,
We undoubtedly carry baggage, trauma, memories, past experiences from the people we have dated and loved and been connected to. And some of that baggage is not great, is not pleasant. And it's perhaps something that we're not ready to unpack yet. But does that mean that if you have not done all the necessary healing, you should hold off on love? Or can you equally heal whilst being with someone new, someone who treats you well and helps you into that kind of self-acceptance,|||毫无疑问，我们身上都背负着行李、创伤、回忆以及与我们曾约会过、爱过和接触过的人有关的过去经历。其中一些行李并不好受，并不愉快。这也许是我们还没准备好去揭开的伤疤。但这是否意味着，如果你还没有完成所有必要的治愈，你就应该对爱情按暂停键呢？还是说，当和一个新的人在一起时——一个对你很好、能帮你走向自我接纳的人——你同样可以得到治愈？
self-love journey? Today we are joined by a brilliant guest who is going to talk us through a little bit about this very idea about healing past trauma in a new relationship. Welcome, Tasha, otherwise known as Real Talk Therapist. Thanks for joining us. Oh, thank you for having me. So if people are not familiar with your work, you are incredible. You post this just amazing content that is like factual, reasonable. You have, obviously you have a therapy. you are a therapist in your real life, in your life.
self-love journey? Today we are joined by a brilliant guest who is going to talk us through a little bit about this very idea about healing past trauma in a new relationship. Welcome, Tasha, otherwise known as Real Talk Therapist. Thanks for joining us. Oh, thank you for having me. So if people are not familiar with your work, you are incredible. You post this just amazing content that is like factual, reasonable. You have, obviously you have a therapy. you are a therapist in your real life, in your life.|||自我爱护之旅？今天我们邀请到了一位杰出的嘉宾，她将为我们详细讲解关于在新恋情中治愈过去创伤的想法。欢迎塔莎（Tasha），也就是大家熟知的真实谈话治疗师（Real Talk Therapist）。感谢你的加入。哦，谢谢邀请我。如果大家对你的工作还不太熟悉，你真的很棒。你发布的内容简直太棒了，既真实又在理。你拥有，显然你从事心理治疗。你在现实生活中是一名治疗师，在你的生活中。
Can you like briefly introduce yourself and tell us about your work? Yeah. So I am a author, psychotherapist and content creator. So I kind of the very all style is I became a child and adolescent psychotherapist because I really want to work with children and trauma. And then I did my training and I realized that. actually loads of adults have this little child in them that has a story to tell. And so I found myself working with adults and their past traumas.
Can you like briefly introduce yourself and tell us about your work? Yeah. So I am a author, psychotherapist and content creator. So I kind of the very all style is I became a child and adolescent psychotherapist because I really want to work with children and trauma. And then I did my training and I realized that. actually loads of adults have this little child in them that has a story to tell. And so I found myself working with adults and their past traumas.|||你能简单自我介绍一下并谈谈你的工作吗？好的。我是一名作家、心理治疗师和内容创作者。我的整个风格是，我成为一名儿童和青少年心理治疗师是因为我真的很想从事儿童和创伤方面的工作。后来我完成了培训，我意识到其实很多成年人的内心里都住着这样一个有故事的小孩。于是我发现自己开始和成年人及其过去的创伤打交道。
And actually particularly like on the topic, like you said, like a lot of people will find me when they're in a safe relationship and suddenly all their triggers are being pushed. And then we'll start to kind of work together to understand what that is and where that's coming from. And then I also have a social media platform where I share free content because obviously not everybody can access therapy, but everybody can access Instagram or TikTok.
And actually particularly like on the topic, like you said, like a lot of people will find me when they're in a safe relationship and suddenly all their triggers are being pushed. And then we'll start to kind of work together to understand what that is and where that's coming from. And then I also have a social media platform where I share free content because obviously not everybody can access therapy, but everybody can access Instagram or TikTok.|||事实上，正如你所说，关于这个话题，很多人找到我时，往往是他们正处于一段安全的亲密关系中，结果突然间他们所有的精神触发点都被触动了。然后我们会开始一起探讨那是什么以及它的根源在哪里。此外，我还有一个社交媒体平台，我在那里分享免费内容，因为显然不是每个人都能接受心理治疗，但每个人都能使用Instagram或TikTok。
So I do my best to share healing prompts, tips, and encouragement to anybody that needs it. And then obviously through my book as well. For those of you who do not or have not read this book, it is amazing. It's called Real Talk. So like you'll be able to find it. And it's kind of like one of those books.
So I do my best to share healing prompts, tips, and encouragement to anybody that needs it. And then obviously through my book as well. For those of you who do not or have not read this book, it is amazing. It's called Real Talk. So like you'll be able to find it. And it's kind of like one of those books.|||所以我尽我所能向任何需要的人分享治愈提示、建议和鼓励。当然，还有通过我的书。对于那些没有或者还没读过这本书的人来说，它真的太棒了。它叫《真实谈话》（Real Talk）。所以你们可以很容易找到它。它有点像那种……
We were talking about this before, that everyone, I think, needs no matter how much therapy you have done, because it will introduce you to just so many concepts around healing, around living your best life that we often don't think about. So I would very much recommend going out and grabbing that. And I just want to say thank you for coming on once again. Obviously, we're talking about healing whilst in a new relationship. I think it is so interesting what you said about how a lot of you. How a lot of people come to you and find you when they finally are in this like safe relationship. They're experiencing safe, healthy love for the first time. And that is scary to them.
We were talking about this before, that everyone, I think, needs no matter how much therapy you have done, because it will introduce you to just so many concepts around healing, around living your best life that we often don't think about. So I would very much recommend going out and grabbing that. And I just want to say thank you for coming on once again. Obviously, we're talking about healing whilst in a new relationship. I think it is so interesting what you said about how a lot of you. How a lot of people come to you and find you when they finally are in this like safe relationship. They're experiencing safe, healthy love for the first time. And that is scary to them.|||我们之前讨论过这个，我认为无论你做了多少次心理治疗，每个人都需要它，因为它会向你引入许多关于治愈、关于过上最好生活的概念，而这些是我们平时往往不会去思考的。所以我非常推荐大家去买一本。我只想再次感谢你来到节目中。很显然，我们正在讨论在一段新感情中疗愈。我觉得你刚才说的那些真的很有趣——很多人是如何找到你的，当他们终于处于这样一段安全的关系中时。他们第一次体验到安全、健康的爱。而这让他们感到害怕。
I feel like that's because a lot of past relationships and experiences can sometimes cause us harm. Like love is one of the most vulnerable things, one of the most vulnerable emotions that we can have. And so there is going to be trauma that comes along with that. I feel like anything that is beautiful, always carries the underside of darkness or a way that it can be manipulated. What are some of the examples or maybe like instances of past trauma that you have come across that we tend to carry into new relationships? Yeah, I think a lot of the time when people think about trauma, they think of the really big things, which obviously absolutely are valid types of trauma, but it's not only those things that can be trauma that we carry. So yes,
I feel like that's because a lot of previous relationships and experiences can sometimes cause us harm. Like love is one of the most vulnerable things, one of the most vulnerable emotions that we can have. And so there is going to be trauma that comes along with that. I feel like anything that is beautiful, always carries the underside of darkness or a way that it can be manipulated. What are some of the examples or maybe like instances of past trauma that you have come across that we tend to carry into new relationships? Yeah, I think a lot of the time when people think about trauma, they think of the really big things, which obviously absolutely are valid types of trauma, but it's not only those things that can be trauma that we carry. So yes,|||我觉得这是因为过去的许多关系和经历有时会对我们造成伤害。就像爱是最脆弱的事物之一，是我们能拥有的最脆弱的情感之一。因此，伴随而来的必然会有创伤。我觉得任何美好的事物，背后总是暗藏阴暗面，或者有被操纵的可能。你遇到过哪些把过去的创伤带入新关系的例子或实例？是的，我认为很多时候，当人们想到创伤时，他们会想到那些非常重大事情，这些当然绝对是有效的创伤类型，但我们身上携带的创伤并不仅仅局限于这些。所以是的，
there could be things like abuse or neglect that we're. had from childhood or even in relationships that we had in adulthood. But there could also be really small traumas. They call them little T's, I think they call them, I've forgotten now small teas, little T's. It could be as small as being a baby and having a parent who never picked you up when you were crying. And that might sound like a small thing at first, but actually it opens time and time again. you learn as a baby that nobody's there for me, nobody can attend to my needs, and so I have to, you know, fend for myself. So even those little small things, or even a parent who doesn't
there could be things like abuse or neglect that we're. had from childhood or even in relationships that we had in adulthood. But there could also be really small traumas. They call them little T's, I think they call them, I've forgotten now small teas, little T's. It could be as small as being a baby and having a parent who never picked you up when you were crying. And that might sound like a small thing at first, but actually it opens time and time again. you learn as a baby that nobody's there for me, nobody can attend to my needs, and so I have to, you know, fend for myself. So even those little small things, or even a parent who doesn't|||可能会有来自童年甚至成年期亲密关系中的虐待或忽视。但也可以是非常小的创伤。他们称之为小t（little T），我想他们是这么叫的，我记不清了，小t，小t。它可能小到当你还是个婴儿时，父母在你哭泣时从不抱你。起初这听起来可能是一件小事，但实际上它一次又一次地显现。你在还是婴儿时就明白，没有人会陪着我，没有人能照顾我的需求，所以我只能，你知道的，靠自己。所以即使是这些小事情，甚至是一个父母……
give that much eye contact, or a parent who calls you a cry baby as a child, you know, you internalise all of these experiences and you expect them in your adult relationship, so that's a friendship or in your romantic relationships. And then the other thing is that, you know, when you've had those traumas or those experiences, it kind of shapes your brain in a particular way. And so you, even though those things don't feel comfortable, they feel familiar.
give that much eye contact, or a parent who calls you a cry baby as a child, you know, you internalise all of these experiences and you expect them in your adult relationship, so that's a friendship or in your romantic relationships. And then the other thing is that, you know, when you've had those traumas or those experiences, it kind of shapes your brain in a particular way. And so you, even though those things don't feel comfortable, they feel familiar.|||不怎么和你进行眼神交流，或者一个在小时候叫你“爱哭鬼”的父母，你知道的，你会将所有这些经历内化，并期望在你的成年关系中——无论是友谊还是浪漫关系——也会遇到这种情况。另一件事是，你知道的，当你经历过这些创伤或经历时，它会以某种特定方式塑造你的大脑。所以你，尽管那些事情感觉并不舒服，但它们让你感到熟悉。
And so you find ways to reenact them. One thing that I find when people are in a safe relationship, their brain starts to panic. Like, wait, he texts me. back? Like when I text, he texts me back. What is going on? Like, what is this about? And we might get the ick or we might, you know, start to think that he's in genuine or the person's in genuine. But it's just the alarm system in our brain is saying, this is very different and I don't know if I trust it yet. Yeah, I can often look like that. That's actually so interesting
And so you find ways to reenact them. One thing that I find when people are in a safe relationship, their brain starts to panic. Like, wait, he texts me. back? Like when I text, he texts me back. What is going on? Like, what is this about? And we might get the ick or we might, you know, start to think that he's in genuine or the person's in genuine. But it's just the alarm system in our brain is saying, this is very different and I don't know if I trust it yet. Yeah, I can often look like that. That's actually so interesting|||因此你会寻找各种方式去重现它们。我发现的一点是，当人们处于一段安全的关系中时，他们的大脑开始恐慌。比如：等等，他回我信息了？当我发信息时，他回了。这到底是怎么回事？这算怎么回事？我们可能会感到反感，或者我们可能会（你知道的）开始认为他或这个人不够真诚。但这只是我们大脑中的警报系统在说：这太不一样了，我还不知道是否该信任它。是的，经常会表现成这样。这其实太有趣了
because I've had that experience and you were saying, oh, they start like texting me back. They want to see me. And I remember when I like, first started seeing my partner and he was so like adamant that he wanted to make plans. And I was like, is this guy love bombing me? Like, is this guy a psychopath? Like, why does he want to see me so much? Like, what's his problem? But it's so true.
because I've had that experience and you were saying, oh, they start like texting me back. They want to see me. And I remember when I like, first started seeing my partner and he was so like adamant that he wanted to make plans. And I was like, is this guy love bombing me? Like, is this guy a psychopath? Like, why does he want to see me so much? Like, what's his problem? But it's so true.|||因为我有过这种经历，你刚才说，哦，他们开始回我信息了。他们想见我。我记得当我刚开始和我的伴侣交往时，他非常坚决地想要把约会计划定下来。当时我就想：这家伙是在对进行爱情轰炸吗？这家伙是个精神病吗？他为什么这么想见我？他有什么毛病？但事实确实如此。
We are so used to what we feel like comfortable and familiar with that we try and recreate that because that is like the only reality that we've ever known. How does like these, because it's not just past relationship patterns, right? Well, I guess it is. It's past relationship patterns, but not just past romance. relationship patterns. It also has to do with the relationship we have with our parents, our family, our caregivers. How does some of this trauma impact our approach to dating or love maybe through self-sabotage, self-abandonment, settling, a fear response like the one you spoke
We are so used to what we feel like comfortable and familiar with that we try and recreate that because that is like the only reality that we've ever known. How does like these, because it's not just past relationship patterns, right? Well, I guess it is. It's past relationship patterns, but not just past romance. relationship patterns. It also has to do with the relationship we have with our parents, our family, our caregivers. How does some of this trauma impact our approach to dating or love maybe through self-sabotage, self-abandonment, settling, a fear response like the one you spoke|||我们太习惯于那些让我们感到舒适和熟悉的事物，以至于我们试图去重现它们，因为那是我们所知道的唯一现实。这些是如何……因为这不仅仅是过去的恋爱模式，对吧？嗯，我想是的。这是过去的恋爱模式，但不仅仅是过去的浪漫关系模式。它还与我们和父母、家庭、抚养者之间的关系有关。这些创伤是如何通过自我毁灭、自我抛弃、将就、以及像你刚才提到的那种恐惧反应，来影响我们的约会或爱情观的？
about? Yeah. We kind of have, when this happens, we kind of have this unfinished business that needs to be, you know, resolved. And usually like our inner child will be the one that carries that unfinished business and tries to make sure that it's, it gets what it needs. But, yeah, often we don't know how to, we know, we know what we want to receive. We know we want to receive love or to iron out our unfinished business, but we don't know how to do that. And then that's where the kind of self-sabotagey or destructive things can happen.
about? Yeah. We kind of have, when this happens, we kind of have this unfinished business that needs to be, you know, resolved. And usually like our inner child will be the one that carries that unfinished business and tries to make sure that it's, it gets what it needs. But, yeah, often we don't know how to, we know, we know what we want to receive. We know we want to receive love or to iron out our unfinished business, but we don't know how to do that. And then that's where the kind of self-sabotagey or destructive things can happen.|||是的。当这种情况发生时，我们内心有一种“未了的事”需要去解决。通常，我们内心的那个小孩会承载着那些未了的心愿，并试图确保它能得到所需的东西。但是，是的，通常我们不知道该如何——我们知道，我们知道自己想得到什么。我们知道我们想得到爱，或者想解决我们未了的事情，但我们不知道该怎么做。然后，自我毁灭或破坏性的事情就会在这个时候发生。
And one thing that I noticed that if we've had kind of a childhood where maybe our parents let us down or our families let us down in whatever way, many people will respond by being really hypervigilant. Not hypervigilant, sorry. Many people will respond by being very hyper independent when it comes to dating. So they'll kind of say, oh, I don't need anybody. Or it's fine, I'm going to like date those of people, but they don't mean anything to me. there's this kind of like almost like I don't actually need that intimate the intimacy that's just so above me and actually that's fair that's fair of getting too close to somebody because they might let you down and they might reject you yeah and and that's one way that it can kind of
And one thing that I noticed that if we've had kind of a childhood where maybe our parents let us down or our families let us down in whatever way, many people will respond by being really hypervigilant. Not hypervigilant, sorry. Many people will respond by being very hyper independent when it comes to dating. So they'll kind of say, oh, I don't need anybody. Or it's fine, I'm going to like date those of people, but they don't mean anything to me. there's this kind of like almost like I don't actually need that intimate the intimacy that's just so above me and actually that's fair that's fair of getting too close to somebody because they might let you down and they might reject you yeah and and that's one way that it can kind of|||我注意到的一件事是，如果我们经历过这样的童年：也许我们的父母让我们失望了，或者我们的家庭在某种程度上让我们失望了，许多人在面对约会时，反应会变得极其高度警惕。不是高度警惕，抱歉。许多人在约会时会表现得极其高度独立。所以他们会说，哦，我不需要任何人。或者没关系，我会和这些人约会，但他们对我都毫无意义。会有这种感觉，就像我其实不需要那种亲密关系，亲密关系对我来说太遥远了，其实这也是情有可原的，不敢和某人靠得太近是情有可原的，因为他们可能会让你失望，可能会拒绝你。是的，这可能是一种表现形式……
look is that we yeah we almost have this exterior that we tell ourselves an exterior narrative that we tell ourselves that actually gets in the way of us actually receiving what we need and what we want. It sounds a lot like emotional unavailability to be. Like the sense of like I've been hurt in the past. We are so hypervigilant towards threats that may hurt us again in the future that we eliminate any possibility for that. Some of those possibilities, some of those opportunities are actually quite positive, would actually be able to rewire our brain, change our mind.
look is that we yeah we almost have this exterior that we tell ourselves an exterior narrative that we tell ourselves that actually gets in the way of us actually receiving what we need and what we want. It sounds a lot like emotional unavailability to be. Like the sense of like I've been hurt in the past. We are so hypervigilant towards threats that may hurt us again in the future that we eliminate any possibility for that. Some of those possibilities, some of those opportunities are actually quite positive, would actually be able to rewire our brain, change our mind.|||也就是我们会在自己身上披上一层外壳，给自己编织一套外在的叙事，而这实际上阻碍了我们真正去接收我们所需和想要的东西。这听起来非常像情感冷漠或情感不可得。就像那种“我过去曾受过伤”的感觉。我们对未来可能再次伤害我们的威胁保持着高度的警惕，以至于我们消除了任何这种可能性。其中一些可能性、一些机会实际上是非常积极的，甚至能够重塑我们的大脑，改变我们的想法。
it's really interesting what you talk about in terms of the hyper independence because I think that that is a way past trauma shows up in our relationships that is not often recognized because independence is such a celebrated trait in our society especially in like western societies especially in individualistic societies whereby being able to like provide for yourself be your own emotional security your own sense of comfort make all the money that you need is like super admirable. But I think it overlooks this thing of you do need a community. You do need love and connection to sustain yourself in a way.
it's really interesting what you talk about in terms of the hyper independence because I think that that is a way past trauma shows up in our relationships that is not often recognized because independence is such a celebrated trait in our society especially in like western societies especially in individualistic societies whereby being able to like provide for yourself be your own emotional security your own sense of comfort make all the money that you need is like super admirable. But I think it overlooks this thing of you do need a community. You do need love and connection to sustain yourself in a way.|||你谈到的高度独立真的非常有趣，因为我认为这是过去创伤在我们的关系中表现出来的一种不常被认可的方式，因为独立在我们社会中是一个备受推崇的特质，尤其是在西方社会，尤其是在个人主义社会中，能够自给自足、成为自己情绪的安全感来源、拥有自己的舒适感、赚取你需要的所有钱，这简直令人钦佩。但我认为它忽视了这样一件事：你确实需要一个社群。你确实需要爱和连接来在某种程度上维持你的生存。
So how do you think, you know, if you've recognized that you are hyper-independent, how do you almost stop doing that? Like it's such a deeply ingrained behavior. How do you unlearn those behaviors? I think it's about kind of asking yourself the question of what would it be like to receive something that is soft and warm and light and loving? What would that actually feel like? And what ways am I likely to reject it or stop it or block it?
So how do you think, you know, if you've recognized that you are hyper-independent, how do you almost stop doing that? Like it's such a deeply ingrained behavior. How do you unlearn those behaviors? I think it's about kind of asking yourself the question of what would it be like to receive something that is soft and warm and light and loving? What would that actually feel like? And what ways am I likely to reject it or stop it or block it?|||那么你认为，如果你意识到自己过于独立，你该如何停止这样做呢？这是一种根深蒂固的行为。你该如何改掉这些行为？我认为这在于问自己这样一个问题：接受一些柔软、温暖、轻盈且充满爱意的东西会是什么样的？那究竟是什么感觉？我可能会通过什么方式去拒绝它、阻止它或阻断它？
Just kind of noticing it, I think, is the first thing. And just being aware of what it looks like when you receive those things. Like when a friend gives you a compliment, how do you respond? When a friend says, call me whenever you need anything, and then you suddenly need something and you still don't call, like, what is that about? So I think it's like noticing those things of like how you stop yourself from receiving what you actually do deserve, but you're telling yourself that you don't need it for whatever reason. And then I talk a lot about leaning into the cringe.
Just kind of noticing it, I think, is the first thing. And just being aware of what it looks like when you receive those things. Like when a friend gives you a compliment, how do you respond? When a friend says, call me whenever you need anything, and then you suddenly need something and you still don't call, like, what is that about? So I think it's like noticing those things of like how you stop yourself from receiving what you actually do deserve, but you're telling yourself that you don't need it for whatever reason. And then I talk a lot about leaning into the cringe.|||我认为首先要做的是去注意到它。并且去意识到当你接受这些东西时它们是什么样子的。比如当朋友称赞你时，你是如何回应的？当朋友说“你需要任何东西随时给我打电话”，而你突然需要帮助时却依然没有打电话，这到底是为什么？所以我认为，就是要去注意这些事情，看你是如何阻止自己去接受那些你其实应得的东西，却因为某种原因告诉自己你不需要它。然后我经常谈到的一点是：去拥抱那种尴尬感（lean into the cringe）。
Like a lot of people, I think, I believe that the things that we cringe are the things that we actually desperately need, but we're too scared to say. So whether it's cringing at a couple, PDAing and hugging and kissing on the road, maybe that's something that we actually do want to receive. But we're like, ew, that's gross. I'd never want that. Like, maybe you do. Yeah.
Like a lot of people, I think, I believe that the things that we cringe are the things that we actually desperately need, but we're too scared to say. So whether it's cringing at a couple, PDAing and hugging and kissing on the road, maybe that's something that we actually do want to receive. But we're like, ew, that's gross. I'd never want that. Like, maybe you do. Yeah.|||就像很多人一样，我相信，让我们感到尴尬或起鸡皮疙瘩的事物，往往正是我们内心极度渴望却又羞于说出口的东西。所以，无论是看到路边情侣大庭广众之下搂搂抱抱、卿卿我我而感到尴尬，也许那正是我们内心深处其实想要得到的。但我们却会说：呃，太恶心了。我才不想要那种东西。其实，也许你想要。是的。
Samming that a little bit more. Yeah. So I think like noticing when you have those cringy feelings and maybe questioning, what is the need underneath that that I might be communicating through my cringe. When you said that I was like, wow, that is, I actually think that is so accurate. it because the other example I always think of is like, um, cringing at people who, you know, like, um, kind of like always validate their partner, right? I remember seeing this couple on TikTok a little while ago.
Samming that a little bit more. Yeah. So I think like noticing when you have those cringy feelings and maybe questioning, what is the need underneath that that I might be communicating through my cringe. When you said that I was like, wow, that is, I actually think that is so accurate. it because the other example I always think of is like, um, cringing at people who, you know, like, um, kind of like always validate their partner, right? I remember seeing this couple on TikTok a little while ago.|||再深入一点。是的。所以我觉得，当你产生那种尴尬的感觉时，要去注意它，并试着去质疑：在这份尴尬的背后，我可能正在通过这种反应传达什么需求？当你这么说的时候，我当时就想：哇，这真的是……我其实觉得这太准了。因为我总是想到的另一个例子是，呃，看到那些总是对伴侣表示认可的人，会觉得起鸡皮疙瘩，对吧？我记得不久前在TikTok上看到过这样一对情侣。
And it like went kind of viral. It was this example of them doing like a love surge. I don't know if you've seen this. Do you know what I'm talking about? No. Okay. So it's, I'll send it to you because it's this really like, lie-hearted video where this couple is like, when one of us feels a lot of love, we get the,
And it like went kind of viral. It was this example of them doing like a love surge. I don't know if you've seen this. Do you know what I'm talking about? No. Okay. So it's, I'll send it to you because it's this really like, lie-hearted video where this couple is like, when one of us feels a lot of love, we get the,|||这视频当时还挺火的。他们展示的是一种他们称之为“爱意大爆发”（love surge）的东西。我不知道你有没有看过。你知道我在说什么吗？没有。好吧。那好，我会发给你，因为这是一个非常轻松搞笑的视频，这对情侣在视频里说，当他们中的一个人感受到满满的爱意时，我们就会有……
this thing called a love surge and we have to like hug each other and whatnot. And all of these people were like, that is so cringe. Like that is so disgusting. That is like revolting. And I remember watching that feeling that way and then obviously met my partner and was like, I get that. I get it. I wanted that. I wanted to be that loved that someone was willing to like put that online for me.
this thing called a love surge and we have to like hug each other and whatnot. And all of these people were like, that is so cringe. Like that is so disgusting. That is like revolting. And I remember watching that feeling that way and then obviously met my partner and was like, I get that. I get it. I wanted that. I wanted to be that loved that someone was willing to like put that online for me.|||一种叫做“爱意大爆发”的东西，然后我们就必须拥抱彼此什么的。所有这些人都评论说：这太让人脚趾抠地了。这太恶心了。这简直反胃。我记得当时看的时候也是这种感觉，但后来我遇到了我的伴侣，我就想：我懂了。我明白了。我渴望那个。我渴望被那样去爱，渴望有人愿意为了我把这种爱发到网上。
So it is like a very interesting thing how our brain tries to like trick us out of recognizing our needs as like a protective mechanism. in some ways. Do you think there are other like defense mechanisms as well that we kind of put up other than cringe is a big one I think. Are there any others that like we might not be able to recognize? Yeah. I think like there's obviously we can obviously like deny what we need or um but I think also like the role that we play with that person like if we're dating someone.
So it is like a very interesting thing how our brain tries to like trick us out of recognizing our needs as like a protective mechanism. in some ways. Do you think there are other like defense mechanisms as well that we kind of put up other than cringe is a big one I think. Are there any others that like we might not be able to recognize? Yeah. I think like there's obviously we can obviously like deny what we need or um but I think also like the role that we play with that person like if we're dating someone.|||所以这真的是一件非常有趣的事情：我们的大脑如何试图通过某种保护机制来欺骗我们，让我们不去承认自己的需求。在某些方面。你认为除了尴尬感之外，我们还会建立其他防御机制吗？我觉得尴尬感是一个很大的防御机制。还有其他我们可能无法识别的防御机制吗？是的。我认为，很明显，我们显然会否认自己的需求，或者……但我还认为，比如我们在和那个人交往时所扮演的角色，如果我们正在和某人约会。
Um, some of us will if we have childhood wounds or relationship wounds, we might find ourselves wanting to be rescued by our new partner or for them to suddenly fulfill all of our needs. Every single need we've ever had in our lifetime. We want this partner to have to fulfill for us, which is impossible and, you know, poor person, so have to have such a huge responsibility. But yeah, it can feel like, oh, suddenly there's someone, a hero here who can fulfill everything that I need. And that means that we put them on a pedestal. and we expect them to be really perfect. And when they make a mistake, it's absolutely devastating to us.
Um, some of us will if we have childhood wounds or relationship wounds, we might find ourselves wanting to be rescued by our new partner or for them to suddenly fulfill all of our needs. Every single need we've ever had in our lifetime. We want this partner to have to fulfill for us, which is impossible and, you, poor person, so have to have such a huge responsibility. But yeah, it can feel like, oh, suddenly there's someone, a hero here who can fulfill everything that I need. And that means that we put them on a pedestal. and we expect them to be really perfect. And when they make a mistake, it's absolutely devastating to us.|||嗯，如果我们有童年创伤或亲密关系创伤，我们中的一些人可能会发现自己渴望被新伴侣拯救，或者希望他们能突然满足我们所有的需求。我们一生中曾有过的每一个需求。我们希望这个伴侣必须为我们满足，这是不可能的，而且，天哪，可怜的人得承受多么巨大的责任啊。但是，是的，这种感觉就像是，哦，突然间这里出现了一个英雄，能够满足我所需的一切。这意味着我们把他们高高捧起。并且期望他们真的十全十美。而当他们犯错时，这对我们来说简直是毁灭性的打击。
I think, and this is different to like non-negotiable mistakes. Like if it was something huge, like they were unfaithful, that's different. But if it's like a mistake like they didn't respond to your emotions the way that you wanted them to, but you hadn't told them how you want them to respond to your emotions, things like that. It's like we do need those mistakes to happen because we then can grow the relationship. and they can learn about you, you can learn about them. But for some people, it's like, no, I'm done.
I think, and this is different to like non-negotiable mistakes. Like if it was something huge, like they were unfaithful, that's different. But if it's like a mistake like they didn't respond to your emotions the way that you wanted them to, but you hadn't told them how you want them to respond to your emotions, things like that. It's like we do need those mistakes to happen because we then can grow the relationship. and they can learn about you, you can learn about them. But for some people, it's like, no, I'm done.|||我认为，这与那些不可妥协的错误不同。比如如果是像他们不忠这样的大事，那性质就不同了。但如果是一些小错误，比如他们没有以你所希望的方式回应你的情绪，而你之前并没有告诉他们你希望他们如何回应你的情绪，诸如此类的事情。这就像是我们需要这些错误发生，因为只有这样我们才能促进关系的发展。他们能了解你，你也能了解他们。但对某些人来说，他们的态度是：不，我受够了。
I'm out. So, yeah, I think it's that how we deal with mistakes our partner makes and how we put them on a pedestal is also a big one as well. I can once again agree with that. Something that's really interesting about that is like the nitpicking and the sense of like if this love isn't perfect, I don't want it. and constantly looking for problems that actually are not problems, they're just an excuse for us to leave because we're feeling vulnerable.
I'm out. So, yeah, I think it's that how we deal with mistakes our partner makes and how we put them on a pedestal is also a big one as well. I can once again agree with that. Something that's really interesting about that is like the nitpicking and the sense of like if this love isn't perfect, I don't want it. and constantly looking for problems that actually are not problems, they're just an excuse for us to leave because we're feeling vulnerable.|||我撤了。所以，是的，我认为我们如何处理伴侣犯下的错误，以及我们如何将他们高高捧起，这也是一个非常普遍的问题。我对此再次表示赞同。关于这一点，非常有趣的一点是挑剔，以及那种“如果这份爱不是完美的，那我宁愿不要”的心态，并且不断寻找那些实际上根本不是问题的问题，它们只是我们因为感到脆弱而想要离开的借口。
When you talked about that of like, oh, my partner hasn't responded to my emotional needs, but I've never told them why, or small things like, oh, they didn't text me back within like two hours, they must hate me, the relationship is over. And you could sometimes tell yourself, like, well, that's a non-negotiable for me, when actually it's just you feeling quite triggered by their response. and it's really more symbolic of something deeper.
When you talked about that of like, oh, my partner hasn't responded to my emotional needs, but I've never told them why, or small things like, oh, they didn't text me back within like two hours, they must hate me, the relationship is over. And you could sometimes tell yourself, like, well, that's a non-negotiable for me, when actually it's just you feeling quite triggered by their response. and it's really more symbolic of something deeper.|||当你谈到那种情况，比如：哦，我的伴侣没有回应我的情感需求，但我从来没有告诉过他们原因；或者像一些小事，比如：哦，他们没有在两小时内回我信息，他们一定恨我，这段关系结束了。有时你会对自己说，好吧，这是我的底线（不可妥协的事），而实际上这只是你被他们的回应深深触发了。这其实象征着更深层次的东西。
Like you are actually not ready for this. You're not prepared to be vulnerable with them. So I think it's actually really interesting because this really leads into my next question, the sense of like a healthy relationship will challenge you. It will cause you to question how you perhaps approached love in the past. Do you think that there is a necessary level of healing we need to do before getting into a new relationship?
Like you are actually not ready for this. You're not prepared to be vulnerable with them. So I think it's actually really interesting because this really leads into my next question, the sense of like a healthy relationship will challenge you. It will cause you to question how you perhaps approached love in the past. Do you think that there is a necessary level of healing we need to do before getting into a new relationship?|||就像你其实还没准备好迎接这一切。你还没准备好在他们面前展露脆弱。所以我认为这真的非常有趣，因为这直接引出了我的下一个问题：那种“健康的亲密关系会挑战你”的感觉。它会让你开始质疑自己过去对待爱情的方式。你认为在进入一段新感情之前，我们是否需要达到一定程度的治愈？
or is it like we can, is it that so that we can just heal in another relationship straight off the bat? Oh, I think a bit of both. I'll do a little bit of sharing here. So I actually got married this year, like she. Congratulations. Oh my God, that's so exciting. Thank you.
or is it like we can, is it that so that we can just heal in another relationship straight off the bat? Oh, I think a bit of both. I'll do a little bit of sharing here. So I actually got married this year, like she. Congratulations. Oh my God, that's so exciting. Thank you.|||还是说我们可以直接在另一段感情中边谈边疗愈？哦，我觉得两方面都有吧。我在这里分享一点个人的经历。其实我今年结婚了，就像她……恭喜啊。天哪，太让人兴奋了。谢谢。
Wow, so fun. And I actually met my husband when we were 18, but it didn't work out. And then we reconnected with we were 28. That is a love story. And yeah. And for it. actually when we reconnected, everything just made so much sense.
Wow, so fun. And I actually met my husband when we were 18, but it didn't work out. And then we reconnected with we were 28. That is a love story. And yeah. And for it. actually when we reconnected, everything just made so much sense.|||哇，太棒了。其实我和我丈夫18岁时就认识了，但当时没能走到一起。后来我们在28岁时又重新联系上了。这真是一个爱情故事。是的。而且说实话。其实当我们重新联系上时，一切都变得那么顺理成章。
But by that time, I had had five years of therapy. He had not had therapy before, but he had gone for a really big life-changing thing that had happened for him. And so we had both changed in a way. We were still the same people, but we had a new emotional maturity.
But by that time, I had had five years of therapy. He had not had therapy before, but he had gone for a really big life-changing thing that had happened for him. And so we had both changed in a way. We were still the same people, but we had a new emotional maturity.|||但到那个时候，我已经接受了五年的心理治疗。他以前没有接受过心理治疗，但他经历了一件对他人生产生重大改变的事情。所以我们在某种程度上都变了。我们依然是以前的我们，但我们拥有了新的情感成熟度。
Whereas when we were 18, who was so emotionally immature? There was like nothing could have, Nothing could have seriously happened at that time. But I think there is something of like some healing does have to take place, some kind of self-awareness has to take place for you to be, or to even just start that self-awareness journey is a great bonus. Like to then be able to go into a relationship with somebody else
Whereas when we were 18, who was so emotionally immature? There was like nothing could have, Nothing could have seriously happened at that time. But I think there is something of like some healing does have to take place, some kind of self-awareness has to take place for you to be, or to even just start that self-awareness journey is a great bonus. Like to then be able to go into a relationship with somebody else|||而在我们18岁的时候，谁不是那么情感不成熟呢？当时根本不可能发生……当时根本不可能有什么真正认真的结果。但我认为确实存在这样一种情况：必须进行一定程度的治愈，必须产生某种自我觉察，你才能……或者仅仅是开启这段自我觉察之旅，就是一个巨大的收获。就像然后能够与另一个人建立亲密关系一样……
is also going to have all their own stuff, all their own histories, all their own baggage. and almost when you're in a relationship, it's almost like there's all this junk on the floor and you've got to work out together, okay, that one is mine, I'll take this, this bet is yours, that's mine, that's mine. And you're almost like looking at the mess in between you and working out, divvying up, okay,
is also going to have all their own stuff, all their own histories, all their own baggage. and almost when you're in a relationship, it's almost like there's all this junk on the floor and you've got to work out together, okay, that one is mine, I'll take this, this bet is yours, that's mine, that's mine. And you're almost like looking at the mess in between you and working out, divvying up, okay,|||对方身上也会带着他们自己的所有问题、所有的历史、所有的包袱。当你们身处一段亲密关系中时，几乎就像地上堆满了各种垃圾，你们必须一起去厘清：好吧，那个是我的，我来拿这个；这个是你的；那是我的，那是我的。你们几乎就像是在看着你们之间的这一地鸡毛，然后一起去解决、去分工：好吧，
what is the stuff that I'm taking accountability for and what stuff are you taking accountability for? But if we don't have that self-awareness, we can't do that. We'll be like, oh, that stuff is all yours. that's like none of that's mine i've got nothing to do with all that stuff oh my god that's so true also that is such a beautiful story that you met at 18 and it shows that like people can change but they can change in parallel
what is the stuff that I'm taking accountability for and what stuff are you taking accountability for? But if we don't have that self-awareness, we can't do that. We'll be like, oh, that stuff is all yours. that's like none of that's mine i've got nothing to do with all that stuff oh my god that's so true also that is such a beautiful story that you met at 18 and it shows that like people can change but they can change in parallel|||哪些是我要承担责任的，哪些是你要承担责任的？但如果我们没有这种自我觉察，我们就无法做到这一点。我们会觉得：哦，那些东西全都是你的。那些东西没有一件是我的，我和那些乱七八糟的事一点关系都没有。天哪，太对了！而且这是一个多么美丽的爱情故事：你们18岁相识，这表明人是会改变的，但他们可以平行改变……
or like change in a way that looks different from the outside but it makes them more compatible i think it's a really that's a really beautiful story in terms of also like how people can change in a relationship alongside each other even if it looks different so congratulations on getting married. That's so amazing. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
or like change in a way that looks different from the outside but it makes them more compatible i think it's a really that's a really beautiful story in terms of also like how people can change in a relationship alongside each other even if it looks different so congratulations on getting married. That's so amazing. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical|||或者说以一种从外表看起来不同但却让他们更契合的方式改变。我认为这是一个非常……这真是一个非常美丽的故事，关于人们如何在亲密关系中彼此相伴、共同成长，即使外表看起来有所不同。所以祝贺你结婚。太棒了。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理坚韧、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些不切实际的……
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look|||以及那些充斥着健康产业的、过于复杂的伪科学。行业。我们曾深信植物油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你终将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么鬼关系？好吧，你可以在
Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me. just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me. just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.|||《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大。全是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，不过先让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆上台面了。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade|||谢谢你帮我把话说完。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《吸取教训》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。值此心理健康意识月之际，我将带来我过去十多年的……
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,|||在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tript Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,|||是因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？还是你成为一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。绝对是。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.|||在我的新播客《吸取教训》中，我们将就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《吸取教训》（Learn the hard way）并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.|||随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她言词中明显的矛盾之处。由此引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，旨在证明真相。你曾多次篡改过这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大批网络侦探出动才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的规律。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted|||另外两名男子也经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《困于爱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉
on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we're going to track back now because like we're talking about marriage. We're going to talk about the opposite. I think sometimes people jump from one relationship to another very quickly to avoid healing. Is that something that you've seen? Why do you, why do you think that is? Yeah, I'm actually currently reading a book. It's called Really Good Actually. It's literally called Really Good Actually. Really good actually.
on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we're going to track back now because like we're talking about marriage. We're going to talk about the opposite. I think sometimes people jump from one relationship to another very quickly to avoid healing. Is that something that you've seen? Why do you, why do you think that is? Yeah, I'm actually currently reading a book. It's called Really Good Actually. It's literally called Really Good Actually. Really good actually.|||面临欺诈指控。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《困于爱》播客。我想我们现在要回过头来，因为既然我们在谈论婚姻。我们要谈谈相反的情况。我认为有时人们为了逃避治愈，会非常快地从一段感情跳到另一段感情。这是你见过的情况吗？你认为为什么会这样？是的，我其实最近正在读一本书。书名叫《真的很好》（Really Good Actually）。书名真的就叫《真的很好》。真的很好。
And it's about a woman who is in a relationship from age like 18 and they get married at 28 and then they get divorced two years later. So it's like a huge, it's a huge trauma. But she goes for a phase of just dating constantly, constantly dating. And I think it's that thing of like emotionally availability to ourselves. It is, when we end a relationship or leave a relationship, we actually do have to be in a space of aloneness that a lot of us are terrified of. We're taught that aloneness is, you know,
And it's about a woman who is in a relationship from age like 18 and they get married at 28 and then they get divorced two years later. So it's like a huge, it's a huge trauma. But she goes for a phase of just dating constantly, constantly dating. And I think it's that thing of like emotionally availability to ourselves. It is, when we end a relationship or leave a relationship, we actually do have to be in a space of aloneness that a lot of us are terrified of. We're taught that aloneness is, you know,|||讲的是一个女人从18岁左右就开始谈恋爱，28岁结婚，然后在两年后离婚的故事。所以这就像是一个巨大的创伤。但她经历了一个不断约会、不断约会的阶段。我认为这就是对自己情感开放度的问题。也就是，当我们结束一段感情或离开一段关系时，我们其实必须处于一种孤独的状态中，而这正是我们许多人所恐惧的。我们被灌输的观念是，孤独是……
the worst thing anyone could experience and that we should avoid being alone at all the time. There's a whole air about being alone. And I think even like a lot of single people that I know and friends that I know often feel quite judged for me. single at a particular age because of this kind of judgment. And so I think when we are finally alone, first we have to sit with that, oh, I'm alone, what does that mean?
the worst thing anyone could experience and that we should avoid being alone at all the time. There's a whole air about being alone. And I think even like a lot of single people that I know and friends that I know often feel quite judged for me. single at a particular age because of this kind of judgment. And so I think when we are finally alone, first we have to sit with that, oh, I'm alone, what does that mean?|||一个人能经历的最糟糕的事情，我们应该时刻避免独处。社会上弥漫着一种对孤独的偏见。而且我认为，甚至像我认识的许多单身人士和朋友，经常因为这种评判而在特定年龄单身时感到被评判。所以我认为，当我们终于独处时，首先我们必须去面对这种感觉：哦，我孤独了，这意味着什么？
But also we have to sit with all the grief of grieving that relationship. And when we are grieving in a relationship, it often brings up other experiences of grief that we've had in our lives. So if we've lost a parent or a friend or if we're also grieving the part of ourselves that was in that relationship or the life stages that we've done. We went through in that relationship. We're grieving a lot, basically. And nobody wants to sit in their grief.
But also we have to sit with all the grief of grieving that relationship. And when we are grieving in a relationship, it often brings up other experiences of grief that we've had in our lives. So if we've lost a parent or a friend or if we're also grieving the part of ourselves that was in that relationship or the life stages that we've done. We went through in that relationship. We're grieving a lot, basically. And nobody wants to sit in their grief.|||但同时我们也必须去面对因哀悼那段感情而带来的所有悲伤。当我们在哀悼一段关系时，它往往会唤起我们生活中经历过的其他悲伤体验。所以如果我们失去了父母或朋友，或者我们也在哀悼那段关系中属于我们自己的那部分，或者我们在那段关系中经历的人生阶段。基本上，我们在哀悼很多东西。而且没有人愿意沉浸在悲伤中。
Like, it's not the most fun thing to do. And also we're in a culture, which is, you know, grief avoidant. We don't like to talk about death or losses or endings. We just move on to the next thing. And I think that's where then there's this idea of like, okay, there's a song, isn't there? And they're like a, I can't remember her name now.
Like, it's not the most fun thing to do. And also we're in a culture, which is, you know, grief avoidant. We don't like to talk about death or losses or endings. We just move on to the next thing. And I think that's where then there's this idea of like, okay, there's a song, isn't there? And they're like a, I can't remember her name now.|||这并不是什么最有趣的事。而且我们身处一种逃避悲伤的文化中。我们不喜欢谈论死亡、失去或结局。我们总是直接进入下一件事。我认为这就是为什么会有这种想法，好吧，有一首歌，对吧？里面好像有个……我现在记不起她的名字了。
But there's a song that's like, move on to the next one or something. There's like, yeah, there's like so many phrases of like, if one thing that works out, move on to the next thing. Oh, it's like, thank you next by Ariana Grande. Yeah, yeah. Is it that? Okay.
But there's a song that's like, move on to the next one or something. There's like, yeah, there's like so many phrases of like, if one thing that works out, move on to the next thing. Oh, it's like, thank you next by Ariana Grande. Yeah, yeah. Is it that? Okay.|||但有一首歌是唱着“走向下一个”之类的。有很多这样的词组，比如如果一件事没成，就进行下一件。哦，就像爱莉安娜·格兰德（Ariana Grande）的《Thank U, Next》。对，对。是这个吗？好的。
Yeah, yeah. I was like, wrapping my brain. So it's like, yeah, it's our way of coping, but it's obviously not great for us in the long run. It's just a temporary, a temporary distraction. And avoidance as well. when you said it sometimes we're so afraid of being alone and we're afraid of our solitude. If you have been in a relationship for a while or if you've been in an unhealthy relationship
Yeah, yeah. I was like, wrapping my brain. So it's like, yeah, it's our way of coping, but it's obviously not great for us in the long run. It's just a temporary, a temporary distraction. And avoidance as well. when you said it sometimes we're so afraid of being alone and we're afraid of our solitude. If you have been in a relationship for a well or if you've been in an unhealthy relationship|||是的，是的。我刚才一直在绞尽脑汁地想。所以，是的，这是我们应对的方式，但从长远来看，这对我们显然不是件好事。这只是一种暂时的、暂时的分散注意力的手段。也是一种逃避。正如你所说，有时我们如此害怕孤独，害怕我们的独处。如果你曾经谈过一段时间恋爱，或者如果你曾身处于一段不健康的亲密关系中……
where there has been so much intensity, you're almost like addicted to this other person. You're addicted to the excitement, the feeling, the passion, whatever you want to call it. And when that ends, there is a huge hole left behind. A huge, you almost are like in the state of it. of like withdrawal or detox where you are craving like the kind of connection that you previously had you're craving that love and so the first person that walks along you're like you you will do just fine like you are like who needs therapy when I can someone else can like be a distraction for me so I think that's like something that I see quite a lot especially in our
where there has been so much intensity, you're almost like addicted to this other person. You're addicted to the excitement, the feeling, the passion, whatever you want to call it. And when that ends, there is a huge hole left behind. A huge, you almost are like in the state of it. of like withdrawal or detox where you are craving like the kind of connection that you previously had you're craving that love and so the first person that walks along you're like you you will do just fine like you are like who needs therapy when I can someone else can like be a distraction for me so I think that's like something that I see quite a lot especially in our|||那里有着如此强烈的情感碰撞，以至于你几乎对另一个人上瘾了。你对那种兴奋感、那种感觉、那种激情——无论你把它叫什么——上了瘾。当这一切结束时，心里会留下一个巨大的空洞。一个巨大的空洞，你几乎处于一种戒断或排毒的状态，你渴望着你以前拥有的那种连接，你渴望着那种爱，所以当第一个走过来的人出现时，你就会觉得：你，你就挺合适的。你就像是在想：谁需要心理治疗啊，只要有别人能转移我的注意力就行了。所以我觉得这是我经常看到的一种现象，尤其在我们……
20s when it is so easy to find people who want to casually date you like who aren't looking for commitment, who are just down for a fun time. You can go on a dating app, and especially if you're a woman, like, you can find someone pretty quickly who will at least, like, want to get a drink. So it's easy, and that's such a distraction, it's such like a mask, a facade that we put up where it's like, if I don't have to see my trauma, I don't have to deal with it. Yeah. And I think particularly for women or non-binary people, like that can be super liberating because, you know, we live in such a patriarchal misogynist world,
20s when it is so easy to find people who want to casually date you like who aren't looking for commitment, who are just down for a fun time. You can go on a dating app, and especially if you're a woman, like, you can find someone pretty quickly who will at least, like, want to get a drink. So it is easy, and that's such a distraction, it's such like a mask, a facade that we put up where it's like, if I don't have to see my trauma, I don't have to deal with it. Yeah. And I think particularly for women or non-binary people, like that can be super liberating because, you know, we live in such a patriarchal misogynist world,|||二十多岁的时候，太容易找到那些只想和你随意约会、不求承诺、只想找点乐子的人了。你可以上约会软件，特别是如果你是个女性的话，你可以很快找到一个人，至少愿意和你出去喝一杯。这太容易了，这真是一种分散注意力的方式，就像是我们戴上的一个面具、伪装成这样：如果我不需要去正视我的创伤，我就不需要去处理它。是的。我认为特别是对女性或非二元性别者来说，这可能会超级解放，因为，你知道的，我们生活在一个充满父权制和厌女症的世界里，
but suddenly you can go into an app where you have access to so many potential suitors and you decide who you get to see when you see them, how often you see them? It can feel when you've just gone through a breakup where you feel actually quite helpless or with your feelings, like I'm having to hold all these annoying, frustrating, sad feelings,
but suddenly you can go into an app where you have access to so many potential suitors and you decide who you get to see when you see them, how often you see them? It can feel when you've just gone through a breakup where you feel actually quite helpless or with your feelings, like I'm having to hold all these annoying, frustrating, sad feelings,|||但突然之间你可以下载一个应用程序，在那里你可以接触到无数潜在的追求者，你可以决定你想见谁、什么时候见他们、多久见他们一次？当你刚经历了一场分手，感觉自己或自己的情绪相当无助时，这种感觉会油然而生：我不得不独自承受所有这些恼人、沮丧、悲伤的情绪。
what do I do with them? I feel helpless. I know I can feel more liberated and more, um, productive by dating lots of people. It's almost like, you know, yeah, shifting the energy. That is so true and so fascinating. I think you point out something really interesting
我该拿它们怎么办？我感觉自己好无助。我知道，通过和很多人约会，我可以感到更加解放、更加，嗯，更有生产力。这简直就像是，你知道的，对，转换一下能量。这真的太对了，也太迷人了。我觉得你指出了一点非常有趣
where it's like you don't feel in control over the last relationship. So you want to feel more in control. You want to feel more in control. These apps, this like dating system allows you to feel that way. Even if it is just like temporary, even if it is a little bit of delusion. So say you are someone who, who has you broken up with your partner,
那就是你觉得在上一段感情中你失去了掌控感。所以你想获得更多掌控感。你想要感觉更有掌控感。这些应用，这种约会系统能让你产生这种感觉。即使这只是暂时的，即使这带有一点自我欺骗。所以，假设你是一个，一个已经和伴侣分手的人，
there has been things in that past relationship that maybe you haven't healed from, maybe they cheated on you, maybe they were not particularly kind to you, maybe it was like a situation ship and someone who's just treated you poorly has made you feel like you never really deserved anything more. And you find someone amazing.
在过去的感情中有些事情你可能还没有释怀，也许他们背叛了你，也许他们对你不够好，也许那只是一种暧昧关系（situationship），某个待你很差的人让你觉得自己根本不配得到更好的东西。然后你找到了一个非常棒的人。
What are some of the things to look out for in a new relationship that indicate that you have some work to do, that maybe I'm going to use the analogy you gave before, there is some junk on the floor that you need to pick up. I think, I guess one thing is noticing, you kind of named it earlier, like if you're picking at things, if you're picking at,
在一段新的关系中，有哪些迹象表明你还有一些心结需要解开，可能——我要用你之前比喻过的话——地板上有些垃圾你需要去捡起来？我想，我猜其中一点就是注意到，你刚才其实也提到了，比如你在挑刺，如果你在挑剔，
this is a hard one because obviously we talk about red flags and we talk about, you know, obviously being quite hypervigident to if the person you're dating is right for you. But picking at things is almost, like, it's almost like, so my supervisor calls it a now story. So it's almost like you're seeing something in a now, but actually it has nothing to do what's happening in now. It's everything to do what's happening in your past.
这是一个很难的问题，因为显然我们谈论红线（red flags），我们谈论，你知道的，对和你约会的人是否适合你保持高度警惕。但挑刺几乎就像是，几乎就像是，我的主管称之为“当下故事”（now story）。所以这几乎就像你在当下看到了某种东西，但实际上这和现在发生的事情毫无关系。这完全和你过去发生的事情有关。
So maybe you're with someone and they looked at someone passing by, but for you, it triggered you to think about the time when your ex was looking at other people or dating other people behind your, You know, there's this thing of like you start to merge the two realities together. So I think just noticing when you are picking at things, really ask yourself first, where is that coming from? Is it really, you know, from the now, or is it potentially from the past, or is it both? I think the other thing is to notice when you feel safe and when you don't feel safe.
所以也许你和某个人在一起，他们看了一眼路过的人，但对你来说，这触动了你的回忆，让你想起了你的前任背着你偷偷看其他人或者和别人约会的时候，你知道的，这就产生了一种将这两种现实混淆在一起的现象。所以我觉得，只需注意你在挑剔什么，首先要问问自己，这到底是从哪里来的？它真的是，你知道的，源于当下，还是可能源于过去，或者两者兼有？我觉得另一点是去注意你什么时候感到安全，什么时候感觉不到安全。
So some people, they find that they feel absolutely safe with their new person, but it's when they're apart that they don't feel safe and they start to question things and that might be your kind of history of, you know, absence. If you've had parents that are quite absent or if you had a partner that's quite absent, it's going to give you lots of kind of feelings of anxiety when you're away from your new boo, basically.
所以有些人发现，和新伴侣在一起时他们感到绝对安全，但只有在分开时他们才觉得不安全，并开始产生质疑，这可能源于你对，你知道的，分离的经历。如果你曾有过经常缺席的父母，或者你曾有过一个经常缺席的伴侣，当你离开你的新心上人时，基本上就会产生很多焦虑感。
So just kind of when that happens, use it as a time to journal and think about where is that coming from and where else have you experienced that in your life as well. That is incredibly relevant to me when I was like, I'm just sharing so much, Tasha, I'm just using you for free therapy. That's obviously what that's what this sounds like at the point. But I remember when I would be like totally fine when we were around each other. And then as soon as they left, I'd be like, oh, so they hate me. Oh, so this is over.
所以当这种情况发生时，把它当作一个写日记的时间，思考一下这究竟是从哪里来的，以及你在生活中的其他地方是否也经历过类似的事情。这对我来说简直太有共鸣了，我当时就像是，塔莎，我跟你分享了这么多，我只是在把你当成免费的心理咨询。这显然听起来就是这么回事。但我记得每当我们在彼此身边时我都完全没事。然后一旦他们离开，我就会想，哦，所以他们讨厌我。哦，所以这已经结束了。
Or like, what if this relationship isn't right for me? And I realized that it was because it's so easy to feel safe when there's someone there who's going to constantly validate. you, but you have to be able to validate yourself and able to validate what you know about the relationship, what you know about the other person. Adding to that list of kind of signs that indicate unheeled trauma, picking fights or starting fights on things that are super arbitrary. Obviously, you should feel free to express anger, rage, whatever feeling. But there are sometimes things where you're like, I'm going to start this fight because I want to remember. emotionally almost bait this person and see if they're going to leave.
或者像，万一这段感情不适合我呢？我意识到这是因为，当身边有一个会不断肯定你的人时，要感到安全是如此容易，但你必须能够肯定自己，能够肯定你对这段关系的了解，以及你对另一个人的了解。补充一下那些表明未愈合创伤的迹象清单，为一些超级无聊的小事挑起争端或引发争吵。显然，你应该自由地表达愤怒、狂怒或任何感受。但有时你会想，我要挑起这场争端，因为我想记住。在情感上几乎是去引诱这个人，看看他们会不会离开。
I'm going to bring up something that really doesn't matter. I'm actually not bothered by it. But I want to see how far I can push this person. Because you're kind of seeking the sense of like, people have left me in the past, people have abandoned me. I want to know now whether this person is going to be one of those people. So let's put them through a little bit of a test here. I think that is a huge, huge one that we see.
我要挑起一个根本无足轻重的话题。我其实并没有被它困扰。但我想看看我能把这个人逼到什么地步。因为你某种程度上在寻找这样一种感觉，即过去有人离开过我，有人抛弃过我。我现在想知道这个人是不是也会成为那种人。所以让我们对他们进行一点小小的测试吧。我认为这是一个非常非常普遍的现象。
And that's something that you actually need. need to, you need to be really honest about that with yourself because it can become really problematic. Or worse comes to worse, you actually end up losing them and you, and, and you didn't need to. Like, you didn't, this person would have been amazing, but they, but they would like, I don't, I don't feel like this is fair. I don't feel like this is justified. They actually have done the healing themselves to know that they deserve maybe something different. So part of that is like communication and being like, hey, actually I'm not mad about that. I really just wanted to start a fight. Let's unpack that. How do you communicate with your new
而且这确实是你需要，你需要对此对自己非常坦诚，因为它可能会变得非常成问题。或者更糟糕的是，你最终真的失去了他们，而你其实，并且，并且你本不必如此。就像，你本不该这样，这个人本来会非常棒，但他们，但他们会觉得，我感觉这不公平。我感觉这是不合理的。他们自己其实已经完成了疗愈，知道自己可能值得更好的对待。所以其中的一部分就是沟通，说，嘿，其实我不是生那个的气。我真的只是想吵一架。让我们来剖析一下。当你做出那种反应时，你是如何与你的新
partner when you are reacting that way or kind of what you need, whether in those moments where you're trying to nitpick them, trying to push them away, what you actually need then? Yeah. So I really relate to this one because it was me in my 20s. And I remember being in a previous relationship where whenever we went on holiday, the third day would always be an argument, always be an argument, and it will always come from me. And again, it's a thing of like, this is a third day with somebody. How do I know if they still want to spend time with me? So let me just like pick at something to see, you know, unconsciously, not kind of specifically, but like, unconsciously it was like, oh, it's like, it's been so intimate. Let me, it's almost, does it feel
伴侣沟通的？或者当你在那些试图挑刺、试图把他们推开的时刻，你真正需要的是什么？是的。所以我对这一点真的很有共鸣，因为这就是20多岁的我。我记得在上一段感情中，每当我们去度假时，第三天总会爆发争吵，总会爆发争吵，而且总是由我挑起。这又是一个这样的现象：这是和某个人在一起的第三天。我怎么知道他们是否还想和我共度时光？所以我就挑个刺来测试一下，你知道的，在潜意识里，不是针对性的，但潜意识里就像是，哦，这种感觉太亲密了。让我，这几乎是，感觉
safe? So let me pick at something. One thing that helped with my relationship now. So we had the most arguments of our entire relationship in the first year. We actually don't really argue that much. We do challenge each other, but we're not very argumentative couple. But in the first year, loads. And one thing that we did was we had on our phone, because we both relate to conflict in very different ways,
安全吗？所以让我挑个刺吧。有一件事对我现在的这段感情很有帮助。我们在第一年里吵了整段关系中最多的架。其实我们现在不怎么吵架了。我们确实会互相挑战，但我们并不是一个特别爱争吵的情侣。不过在第一年里，吵得可多了。我们做的一件事是，在手机上——因为我们两人处理冲突的方式非常不同，
we had on our phone just a note which said kind of what do I need when there's conflict and what does he need when there's conflict so he needs five minutes, ten minutes to like go reflect think about things whereas I'm someone I want to be like I want answers now so then we came across we have had an agreement of what we would do let's have 10 15 minutes I write down what I need to write down and then I talk to you about it and then you go away and you respond to it. And another thing that I also tell to clients
我们在手机上建了一个便签，上面写着：当发生冲突时我需要什么，当发生冲突时他需要什么。所以他需要五分钟、十分钟去反思、思考事情，而我是一个想要立刻得到答案的人。于是我们达成了共识，我们商量好该怎么做：给我们10到15分钟，我把需要写下来的东西写下来，然后我和你谈谈，接着你走开去消化并做出回应。另一件事我也经常告诉来访者
when they feel triggered in a new relationship is to write down what your triggers are and to share that with your partner. And obviously that list might grow, that's fine. But to share that with your new partner and also tell them, you know, share on the list what you might need when you are triggered. So do you need them to leave you alone?
当他们在新的感情中被触发（triggered）时，就是写下你的触发点是什么，并与你的伴侣分享。显然这份清单可能会变长，这没关系。但要和你的新伴侣分享，并且告诉他们，你知道的，在清单上分享当你被触发时你可能需要什么。比如，他们需要让你一个人待着吗？
Do you need them to give you a hug? Do you need them to say, let's go for a walk? or let me just you stay in the living room where I'll go and make you something to eat or order us something to eat. Whatever it is, you're communicating to them almost like a first aid kit of what to do when you're triggered
你需要他们给你一个拥抱吗？你需要他们说，我们去散步吧，或者让我留在客厅里，还是我去给你做点吃的或者点外卖？无论是什么，你几乎是在向他们传达一份“急救包”，告诉你被触发时该怎么做，
because they're going to be like, oh my gosh, they're triggered, they're angry at me or they're this or this, what the hell do I do in this situation? So you're at least giving them a toolbox that they can make use of and then you're also getting what you need at the same time. That is such a good suggestion, like such a good skill because I'm the same.
因为他们会觉得，天哪，他们被触发了，他们生我的气了，或者他们这是怎么了，在这种情况下我到底该怎么办？所以你至少给他们提供了一个可以派上用场的工具箱，同时你也得到了你真正需要的东西。这真是一个太棒的建议了，真是一个绝佳的技巧，因为我也是这样。
I'm like, I need you to validate. I need you to tell me it's all okay right now, otherwise I'm going to lose my fucking shit. Like I'm going to panic. I'm going to throw up, like not throw up. But I'm just going to feel really upset. I'm going to feel really anxious. I love the idea of that.
我会觉得：我需要你的肯定。我需要你告诉我此刻一切都好，否则我就要彻底崩溃了。我会恐慌。我会想吐，也不是真的想吐。但我就是会觉得非常难过，会感到非常焦虑。我太喜欢这个主意了。
I also think I'm going to add to this. Just if you really struggle with being honest with someone around what's happened in the past, around what you need. Me and my partner do this thing called vulnerable chats where we'll be like, hey, I want to have vulnerable chats tonight. Like tonight is the night that we're going to have vulnerable chats. And so we both kind of get into a headspace of like, okay, like, let's be a little bit nicer to each other.
我也觉得我要补充一点。如果你真的很难对别人坦诚过去发生了什么、你需要什么。我和我的伴侣会做一件叫做“脆弱聊天”（vulnerable chats）的事，我们会说，嘿，今晚我想来一次脆弱聊天。今晚就是我们要进行脆弱聊天的时间。于是我们俩都会进入这样一种心态，即，好吧，让我们对彼此更好一点。
Not that we ever mean, but like let's be particularly gentle. Let's like make this a gentle environment and set ourselves up for success here so that neither person feels, you know, not threatened. but like, yeah, threatened by the other person, not because the other person is trying to be threatening, but just because they're not prepared for what's happening. Like they're not prepared for a big reveal or like a big truth session. So I think that that is, but I'm going to use your skill.
倒不是说我们以前刻薄，而是说让我们特别温柔。让我们把这里变成一个温柔的环境，为成功做好铺垫，这样双方都不会感到，你知道的，不是受到威胁，而是，是的，被对方威胁——并不是因为对方试图构成威胁，而只是因为他们没有为主办的事情做好准备。就像他们没有准备好迎接一个重大的揭露或一次深刻的真心话大冒险。所以我觉得，不过我也要用你的技巧。
I'm going to use your little tip as well. I think that's amazing. So I have one final question for you. What do you think is your perspective here? Do you need to be fully healed before you enter into a new relationship? or can you allow love to heal you or can you heal whilst you're in a new relationship? So I don't believe in the idea of anyone being fully healed. Yeah, like you read the book like the first page.
我也要用你的小贴士。我觉得这太棒了。所以我有最后一个问题问你。你认为你的观点是什么？在进入一段新的感情之前，你需要完全疗愈吗？还是你可以让爱情来疗愈你，或者你可以在一段新的感情中进行疗愈？我不相信任何人能完全疗愈这种说法。是的，就像你读了一本书的第一页。
Yeah. My therapist being like, that's why I asked you that question. Yeah, that's not real. I'm setting you up for a particular answer. So the first page in my book is it's me in therapy and saying, oh my god i can't wait to be this amazingly fully healed person it's going to be amazing i can just like live the rest of my life and then my therapist is like yeah tasha that's not real there's no such thing and like my jaw dropping and feeling like my parent just told me that
对啊。我的治疗师就说：“这就是我问你那个问题的原因。”是的，那不是真的。我在引导你走向一个特定的答案。所以我的书的第一页就是我在做心理咨询，然后说：“天哪，我迫不及待地想成为一个完全疗愈好的人了，那一定太棒了，我就可以过好我的余生了。”然后我的治疗师说：“是的，塔莎，那不是真的。根本没有那种事。”然后我惊掉下巴，感觉就像我父母刚刚告诉我
santa claus does exist um yeah it's like you know there is no idea of this fully healed person we are going to be healing and evolving for the rest of our lives right until the very end of our lives. And I think that's the most beautiful thing about being human is that we are going to be always changing and knowing about ourselves more and more each day. I think it does help to have, it definitely helps to have had some healing work before you go into a relationship. I would say it's absolutely vital, but it will add some ease into having, you know, self-awareness of, you know, we are part in the relationship. If you haven't experienced any healing before a relationship, then, you know, it is going to be tough.
圣诞老人其实是存在的一样，嗯，这就好比，你知道的，根本没有“完全疗愈的人”这种说法。我们将用余生的时间去疗愈和进化，直到生命的最后一刻。我觉得这是身为人类最美妙的事情，那就是我们将不断改变，并且每一天对自己的了解都会越来越深入。我觉得，在进入一段感情之前，进行一些疗愈工作确实会有所帮助。我会说这绝对至关重要，但它会为自我觉察带来一些轻松感，你知道的，我们在关系中也是有责任的。如果你在进入感情前没有经历过任何疗愈，那么，你知道的，这过程将会很艰难。
I'm not going to lie. It will be very triggered at times. But it also depends on the person that you're with. And maybe they've done some healing work, or maybe they have some self-awareness. And being in their presence might teach you about your own self-awareness and healing as well. But there are so many, you know, great resources like this podcast
我不会撒谎。有时确实会频繁被触发。但这也要看和你在一起的人是谁。也许他们做过一些疗愈工作，或者他们具备一些自我觉察。身处他们的陪伴中，可能也会教会你了解自己的自我觉察和疗愈。但现在有那么多，你知道的，优秀的资源，比如这个播客
and great books. And, you know, there's so many things that you can access now that even if you are in a relationship and you're like, oh crap, I haven't done years of therapy yet. That's fine, you know, it's never too late. Just it's about giving yourself grace and space. Yeah. Grace, I love the idea of grace.
和好书。而且，你知道的，现在你可以接触到很多途径，即使你正处于一段感情中，而你却在想：“哦糟了，我还没做过几年的心理咨询呢。”没关系，你知道的，什么时候都不晚。这关乎于给予自己恩典（grace）与空间。是的，恩典，我太喜欢“恩典”这个词了。
It's like self-forgiveness. Like, you're never going to be the best, the best partner. Like, you're never going to be a fully perfect partner, parent, friend, colleague, anything. Like, it's always going to be a bit of a work in progress. And I love what you're. said about, I don't think you can ever be fully healed. And you can, you can approach that and be like, that is terrifying. I'm going to hold back from love because I, I remember when I was like dating again after my last relationship, which was terrible, I was like, I don't want to meet the love of my life
这就好比自我宽恕。就像，你永远不会成为最好的，最好的伴侣。就像，你永远不会成为一个完全完美的伴侣、父母、朋友、同事，什么都是。这永远是一个不断完善的过程。我太喜欢你所说的了，我不认为任何人能完全疗愈。你可以用这种态度去面对，并觉得：这太可怕了。我要对爱情退避三舍，因为我，我记得当我上一段糟糕的感情结束后重新开始约会时，我在想：我不想在
as the version of myself I am right now. I don't think that if I met the love of my life, they would love me because there's so much work to be done. And then the more I kind of went on, I was like, well I don't think that I think that if they wouldn't be able to love me as well if I was perfect like there are things that I would want to share with them that wouldn't would be messy and would be ugly but I would hope
以我目前这个版本的状态下去遇到此生挚爱。我不认为如果我遇到了此生挚爱，他们会爱我，因为还有太多问题需要解决。然后随着我不断经历，我想，好吧，我不认为——我觉得如果我很完美的话，他们反而无法真正爱我，因为有些我想与他们分享的东西，会是凌乱的、丑陋的，但我希望
that they would receive that and I would be willing to receive that from them so I think that's a really beautiful place to end it any final thoughts no I guess I was just thinking about what you just said and that was a adding another thing but just another thing that can often sabotage us on a relationship
他们能够接纳这些，而我也愿意接受他们身上的这些。所以我觉得这是一个非常美妙的收尾。还有什么最后的想法吗？没有，我只是在想你刚才说的话，这算是在补充一点，但另一个经常在感情中破坏我们幸福的因素，
is when we're trying to be, yeah, perfect or trying to be perfect for our partner but not actually be our authentic selves. So allow your partner to see the mess. They need to, you need to, let your messes exist together so that you can, like, kill through it together as well. And I think that's really important. And that's when the real relationship happens
就是当我们试图表现得，是的，完美无缺，或者试图为伴侣做到完美，却无法真正做真实的自己时。所以，让你的伙伴看到你的凌乱吧。他们需要，你们需要让彼此的凌乱共同存在，这样你们才能一起度过难关。我觉得这非常重要。而这才是真正的恋爱发生的时候，
is when you can both be really real of each other. Yeah, that's when the real relationship. relationship happens absolutely that's like the perfect place to like that is the perfect final message to leave with the listeners um i really hope that you enjoyed this episode i hope you learned something tasha thank you so much for coming on that was such an amazing kind of insight such a great conversation i feel like i learned a lot where can listeners find you because you are one of my favorite creators i love your work i learn from your work and i think that everyone should have a bit more positivity in their feed.
也就是你们两个能够对彼此完全真实的时候。是的，那才是真正的感情发生的时候。绝对的，这简直是完美的去处——这绝对是留给听众们的完美的最后寄语。嗯，我真的希望你们喜欢这一期节目，希望你们有所收获。塔莎，非常感谢你来做客，这真是太棒的见解，太棒的对话了，我觉得我学到了很多。听众们在哪里可以找到你呢？因为你是我的最爱创作者之一，我喜欢你的作品，从你的作品中获益良多，我认为每个人都应该在信息流里多一点正能量。
Where can they find you on the internet elsewhere? So you can find me on Instagram and TikTok as real talk. Dot therapist. And I also have a substack. And I also have a book. So yeah, lots of places. Yes, the book is called Real Talk. It will be linked in this episode description.
他们在互联网的其他地方哪里可以找到你呢？你可以通过 real talk 点 therapist 在 Instagram 和 TikTok 上找到我。我还有一个 Substack。我还有一本书。所以，是的，有很多地方。对，这本书叫《Real Talk》（真诚对话）。它会被链接在本集简介中。
It's incredible. I really, it is the perfect companion guide if you are, you know, trying to learn more about yourself. Obviously, you can never be fully healed. But trying to just figure out where you sit in the world. and how to be a better version of you and really show up for yourself. So once again, thank you so much. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review
这太棒了。我真的觉得，如果你正试图更多地了解自己，它就是完美的伴侣指南。显然，你永远无法完全疗愈。但只要试着弄清楚你在世界上的位置，以及如何成为一个更好的自己，真正为自己挺身而出。所以再次非常感谢你。像往常一样，如果你喜欢这一期节目，请随时留下五星好评，
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. Make sure you give us a follow at That Psychology Podcast if you have an episode suggestion or just a question, just a thought, a feeling, whatever it may be. We would love to see you over there. And we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify，或者你现在收听节目的任何地方。如果你有节目建议、或者只是一个问题、一个想法、一种感觉，无论是什么，一定要在 That Psychology Podcast 上关注我们。我们很期待在那里看到你。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专门探讨黑男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须去这样做。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这似乎是一场骗局。奥恩斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
随着节目的继续，劳拉——劳拉·奥恩斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客节目《Love Trapped》。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%，可在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。